Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
It feels like it's been such a long time!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today for our 106th episode!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's been...
It's been about a week since the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
Wait!
We did sing together!
Yeah!
Together with all of Advent.
Yes!
Oh well, we had some big announcements too.
When was that though?
It feels like forever ago!
BAU!
Ruffians!
I definitely saw some Ruffians who said it's been a little while since they got to catch FUWAMOCO Morning.
Maybe you forgot.
But to explain a little bit about FUWAMOCO Morning, and for those that are joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
How many hashtags?
Wait, what hashtag?
Yeah, if you use two hashtags, the first one will just kind of sit there and look a little bit silly, Ruffians.
Don't try it, okay?
No.
As in...
90% of the time hot.
I don't know why, but it's like that hot.
Make sure you get Moco-chan to check over your tweet before you hit send, okay?
I do my best.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, we just said something on the Ruffians, right?
But it was bad news, so I was thinking about maybe not... Bad news?
Not sharing?
Well, sometimes, you know, reality is a little bit rough, but... We can't run away from it, Moco-chan!
Well... Let's take a look at the reality.
Anyways!
Another Pero Sighting.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look!
Where was Pero seen this time, Ruffians?
Oh!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It sort of looks like you melted in the summer heat into just one big... Pero pile.
Pero puddle.
Yeah, but... But why is Pero?
Yeah, I don't think this open heart has anything to worry about, actually, Moco-chan.
Why?
I think, you know, this is just a piece of garbage.
Yeah, well... You know, to be honest, whether it's garbage or actually Pero...
In the end, you know.
It's still garbage we're talking about, right?
Right!
Yeah, it's all garbage!
It's just garbage.
Yeah.
Street pizza peril.
This is a pizza you might want to avoid, then.
Don't eat this one.
As well as all the other pizza, too.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
It's too harsh!
What?
Rude!
Ruffians.
Nasty.
Garbage is nasty.
Pero is nasty.
Pero is garbage.
I'm not sure what kind of garbage this is either.
Ruffians, do you have any good guesses?
Maybe it's a bottle cap?
Oh, it was a bottle cap.
BAU BAU!
A pancake?
I don't think this is a pancake.
Gum!
I don't think it's gum.
There's two little dots on it.
Could be rocks, I guess.
Ice cream.
Plastic bag.
A lid.
Something.
A sticker?
Maybe.
It could be anything.
Well, all we know is garbage.
Yeah, we don't know what it is.
BAU BAU!
I guess that was probably the best Pero Sighting, huh?
Because it wasn't really Pero.
I guess it's true.
Oh, it's like a jump scare, right?
It's okay, it was just garbage.
It was just garbage!
What's that?
Oh, it was just a leaf.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, it's just my hair.
You know, just like that.
BAU BAU!
This definitely was not a jump scare, was it?
It was a little bit of a jump scare for me too, but!
Well, Ruffians, you know, we were actually live over on Nerissa's channel together with Advent, and we had a little bit of a collab.
We teamed up all together!
But, not just that, there was a huge
Advent.
Our 3D debut dates were announced!
Exciting!
27 days?
Are you sure it's 27 days?
I'm pretty sure it's like a week.
I see a lot of Ruffians saying, oh it's so far away.
It's not.
Are you sure about that?
Are you taking BAU time into account here?
Yeah.
This is a week at most.
It's a week away.
Okay.
Yeah.
Think about the BAU time, Mocchi!
But we're so nervous, Mocchi!
To be honest, we're so nervous.
We would probably rather debut again in hololive five times over.
Yeah.
We're really nervous.
Yeah, that's how nervous we are.
Yeah, but to start off the 3D debuts, we have Shiori!
On the second act in PMPT.
And then, now, uh, Biboo!
On the next day!
It's a bit confusing, huh?
Yeah, on the next day.
I don't know, after a week goes by, the next weekend we have Nerissa!
And then!
FUWAMOCO on the 10th at 8pm!
But that's not it!
No!
We still have the Advent collab!
On the 17th, all of us all together!
Yeah, but Ruffians!
You can't believe how hard we've been practicing and dreaming for this!
Yeah...
Oh, there's been so many sweats.
Sweats?
So many sweats!
So many... liters of sweat!
No!
What?!
Liters of tears!
Gallons of love!
Not that many tears.
At least a couple bottles of tears.
Yeah, and that's just so far, Ruffians.
Yeah.
Liters of love.
I'm nervous, Moco-chan.
We'll be okay!
We'll do our best, okay!
Please be there cheering for all our Advent doing each and every one of our debuts and being as loud as possible!
Make sure you use the hashtags.
Hashtag Shiorin3D.
Don't forget the N, okay?
Hashtag Biboo3D, not Bijou3D.
Biboo3D.
Hashtag 3DemonDebut.
And hashtag FWMC3D.
Yeah.
Got it?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Oh, Advent 3D.
Yeah.
Don't forget that one too, okay?
BAU BAU!
Make sure, okay, that you'll be there.
Yeah.
Who's Bijou?
He's Bijou, right?
Even mama puppy's like, Biboo.
Biboo!
Bijou.
She's Koseki Bijou.
Koseki Bijou.
Biboo.
BAU BAU!
Don't forget to put it in your calendars.
Maybe there's some Ruffians that don't have calendars.
You could just take a pen and write it on your paw too.
Or try to remember.
BAU BAU!
And well, FUWAMOCO, there's been a lot going on.
You know hololive, there's been so many amazing announcements.
Most recently there was the hololive world tour that was announced that's going on.
But completely separate, actually, we realized that us, FUWAMOCO,
We've kinda been doing our own world tour without us even realizing it!
Yeah!
Where is she now?
Yeah, you know FUWAMOCO.
Just this summer alone, you know, we had the honor of performing in Taipei.
Taipei!
In LA, Los Angeles!
BAU BAU!
And then we were at Japan Expo in Paris!
And then just coming up really soon we're gonna be in
Sydney!
New York City!
Ruffians!
Cities to go and visit!
Ruffians to see!
Japan Expo last week in Paris!
You know, it was so much fun!
You're absolutely amazing!
Everyone was jumping and dancing and energetic!
BAU BAUing along with us!
And you know we got to use our French as much as we could too!
But maybe we went a bit overboard, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Maybe.
Sometimes!
I think it was hard for everyone to understand what we were saying.
FUWAMOCO, transfer!
Transfer!
I'm FUWAMOCO!
I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU.
You're so good at French!
Meshiboku.
BAU BAU.
Yeah, I think we overused it.
Yeah, we went overboard.
But it's okay because this upcoming weekend, you know, we're gonna be in a smash in Australia!
And, uh, that's English.
Good day, me!
Yeah, we're gonna do our best in our Australia too!
What else do you know?
What?
I don't know what all this is.
Makaij.
I'm gonna shake them up.
What?
Makaij.
It's time for FUWAMOCO, right?
Shunpon the barbie, that sounds yummy.
Barbie is barbecue, right?
I don't think this on my soul is something we need to know for Smash.
They may be like, huh?
Yeah, just like in Japan.
We don't want to repeat that, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah, but we're really looking forward to Smash.
Especially, you know, we'll be able to talk closely with some very lucky Ruffians, too!
So excited!
We just had so much fun already, just BAU BAUing all together.
You know, hopefully we can go to even more places around the world and you know, that way maybe if we haven't had the chance to visit near you yet, we can
Hope to see you sometime soon!
Okay.
Got it.
So please let your local event organizers know that you wanna see us!
See FUWAMOCO at your event too, okay?
Thank you, Ruffians!
The unexpected FUWAMOCO World Tour continues!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
New York City breaking dimensions!
We're gonna break down!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know, maybe you've been even busier than FUWAMOCO, and this chance you didn't hear the other big noise.
But, FUWAMOCO!
At the Anime Expo Good Smile Parlor, it was announced that FUWAMOCO Nendoroids are in development!
BAU BAU!
Not just that, Moco-chan!
Not just that, but POP UP 3 figures of us too!
BAU BAU!
We're so excited!
It really means so much to us as huge fans of figures and, you know, good smiles.
Words, figures, Nandroid.
All of them.
We just can't wait to get our paws on them!
Yeah!
Yeah, I need them now!
We're gonna have to be patient.
You're getting them all!
I'm gonna get them all too!
But we haven't talked about how many we need.
Oh, well we talked about how many the Ruffians need, right?
But how many do we need?
Oh, that's another question entirely.
Uh-oh.
Ruffians, what kind of silly expressions and accessories do you think they'll have on their heads?
We wanna know what you're imagining!
Sneeze face!
What is my sneeze face?
That goes without saying.
Is it this?
That's your sleeping face.
There it is!
Sneeze face.
Is that it?
That's all.
Apparel?
No way.
Nendoroids aren't nasty.
You don't get garbage with a nendoroid.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
We want to know what you're imagining, Ruffians!
Let us know again!
You'll definitely need to make sure that you have your camera ready to take photos when we get into your paws, too.
You know, maybe we'll see more doggy of the days with Nanjoy, FUWAMOCO included.
Maybe.
Maybe we'll get to be in the doggy of the days fluff.
Melt melt.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, also you know that FUWAMOCO was busy being sick with food poisoning and kinda stuck in bed.
There are some new voice packs that were released!
This time, Tanabata themed!
Tanabata themed voice packs!
Ruffians, are you familiar with Tanabata?
Do you know what it is?
I always kind of forget a little bit myself.
Ikeri did before.
You like that?
A bit, a bit.
No, you don't know.
Yeah.
Wow.
Tanabata, it's a star festival.
And it celebrates the once a year meeting of the deities and lovers.
Hikoboshi-sama and Orihime-sama.
You know, and everyone writes their wishes on tons of paper slips and hangs them up on bamboo.
Yeah, it's just really, really sweet.
It's a nice festival that's very hopeful.
They only meet that one time in the year.
Yeah, that's why it's so special.
Very romantic.
FUWAMOCO!
We recorded some really cute voice packs around it, so please check them out!
Yeah, you can even hear samples, like one-minute samples of our voice packs in both English and Japanese on the hololive production official song!
Shop!
Yeah, you know, Tanabata Day is kind of a long, long, long kind of day to start.
Well, if you're interested, maybe going on a date together with Moco-chan.
Yeah, in a yukata.
And Fuwawawa, I'm in a maid outfit!
It doesn't seem very Tanabata-themed, huh?
It's Tanabata Day-themed, so you won't want to miss it, okay?
A maid outfit!
A maid outfit.
I'm gonna wear a maid outfit.
Maid outfits work for any situation.
Even though FUWAMOCO, the paws have been hitting the pavement very hard.
Things have been busy, but even us, we were able to take a little moment to celebrate Tanabata too.
You know we wrote special tanzaku for Shirakei Tanabata stream.
You wanna see them?
Wait, no.
We also had personal tanzaku that we shared with Mane-chan and staff.
We wrote down.
And then we're like, okay, we're gonna take a photo for memories.
And then we're like, Mane-chan, look!
These puppies are hungry!
Staff, look at our tanzaku, hi!
This is our tanzaku, hi!
Hi!
We have lots of dreams, right?
BAU BAU!
We hope you had a wonderful Tanabata!
A date with Moco-chan!
Yukata date.
Tanabata date.
Voice part.
If you just go to the hololive production official site, there's a one minute sample!
One minute sample is a lot.
That's like a, you get a one minute date with Moco-chan then.
For free!
Whatever, Fuwama-chu!
Fuwama-chu, yeah!
BAU BAU!
Well you know, like I said, the paws are visiting the pavement.
And, uh,
I'm still a little bit tired.
You know, we've been working really hard and practicing a ton.
Singing, dancing, over and over and over and over.
So you know, we're a bit sore.
Yeah.
Kinda sore puppies.
You know, sometimes practices go from morning to night.
Yeah.
We've never got massages before, but I feel like if there is a time,
That would be nice.
Fuwawa does her best to massage you, but her paws get sore quickly.
Yeah, Moco-chan is like, Fuwawa, can you just kind of like punch here?
There, there, there.
No, no, down.
Down.
Yeah.
There, there, there, there.
It's okay, but then it becomes a bother really quickly because she's picky.
I'm just trying to help.
But, I don't know, Ruffians, like, going to get massages is like a normal thing, right?
But, I don't, I don't, is it a normal thing?
I don't think so.
Just, the idea of maybe somebody that don't know touching the floor from the first, it's just a little bit too much.
It's a bit much, huh?
Yeah.
You know, I think,
My muscles might just tense up and get a bit more stressed and relaxing, huh?
It's an old person thing.
I wouldn't know.
Have y'all ever gotten a massage of Ruffians?
I don't know.
Most people don't get massages.
Did you do something to prepare if you did?
I don't know.
You get them every week?
Oh my goodness.
Really?
Wow, brave.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think that your back needs one.
I hope it feels better soon.
Yeah.
I don't know though.
I think like, if I imagine us trying to get a massage, I think we might just end up being ticklish or laughing or even just running away midway.
I just, I really want to get a scalp massage someday though.
I feel like it's different.
You just gotta make sure that the ears, no touch the ears.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
You know, I'm sort of worried that I might get a headache after.
Because that's usually what happens, huh?
Yeah.
But Nerissa has been kind of talking about wanting a massage too recently, right?
So maybe we can go together or something and then it won't be so scary?
Yeah!
We'll have to see!
But, you know, I do think it's kind of about time that FUWAMOCO maybe take a moment to get a breath of fresh air.
Mia.
BAU BAU!
Wow, you know, Moco-chan, it's a new week, but there's no natto challenge.
Doggie of the Day!
Make sure you challenge yourself this week, okay?
What Doggie of the Day?
Let's take a look at today's Doggie of the Day.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Destiny!
Destiny!
She's so cute, she looks like a stuffed animal.
Right?
Look at those little eyes.
But she's not a stuffed animal.
She's Destiny!
Well Destiny, apparently she can be a little bit of a pain in the tail.
BAU BAU!
Destiny is cute, but also a pain.
Sounds very accurate, though.
Destiny can be a pain!
Right, you know!
Yeah.
Destiny's sometimes nice, sometimes also a pain.
Accurate.
But, uh, I might kind of have heard, you know, kind of heard around, though, that if you give her lots of head pats and attention, that she'll be less of a bother.
Or cuddly, though.
Maybe.
Yes, maybe.
Yeah, not like we know anything, though.
No, no.
BAU BAU!
And next morning!
Let's see where you've been going on the logs.
De-den!
How many sculptures of dogs are on it too? 27!
Oh my gosh!
And real dogs too!
There's lots of dogs.
Sculptures of dogs!
Real dogs!
But it sounds like we need to visit there too, you know.
The resident demon dog!
Right!
Yeah!
It looks so pretty though!
I wanna jump in!
But Moco-chan, if we do that again, you know, we might get put in the cell for mischief.
Ruffians.
Do you think he's okay?
It was worth it.
Be extra sneaky.
Go back to the cell!
No!
We'll just have to... Don't get caught.
Don't get caught.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Rewatching FUWAMOCO Morning 31!
Since 106, quite a number of FUWAMOCO Mornings ago.
We know it's you, Ruffians.
Rewatching old episodes!
Thank you!
Rewatching FUWAMOCO Morning 31 again was nostalgic and energizing.
It told us that former doghouse lighting was running out.
Ran out of hope after the fourth ball went out.
I wonder what the lighting's gonna say.
The lighting situation is like in the current doghouse in Japan.
I sure hope they're going well today.
Going strong.
Strong!
Yeah.
Ah, that's right, though.
We had a lot of problems with the light bulbs, right?
We did.
Well, currently, this doghouse has very good light bulbs.
Probably.
No lighting situation, okay?
Lighting's exciting, but... No, lighting!
Lighting's not exciting.
But important.
Yeah, and the light bulbs are very good, so we have not thought about it.
I'd like to inform you though that we also do not have a ladder.
So when it does become a problem, it will be a problem.
Yeah.
I don't know where to get a ladder.
We'll get there when we get there.
BAU BAU!
Ah, so many things we need to acquire, Mr. Moco-chan.
The quest continues.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions, your Doggie of the Day, your questions, your walks, your Pero Sightings.
Please, please!
Please send us some if you see Pero around.
Use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Don't forget it!
You're an important part of FUWAMOCO Morning, so we're always waiting, okay?
We're waiting!
BAU BAU!
And we have our next stream coming up.
We have De-den!
Ruffians, it's been a long time since we chatted.
And there's some Super Chats that we also wanna read.
We wanna read all your Super Chats!
So we're gonna have a really, really fun time.
Just being able to, you know, have a cozy, comfy chatting time.
Yeah, right!
We really, really need it, right?
So many things!
It might be a bit long.
Yeah, no more food poisoning.
Oh my goodness, no.
Yeah.
I just eat simple things like... Mugamame.
Grapes.
Grapes!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I'm pondering.
And Ruffians, let's take a look at our schedule!
We released a new schedule, but we haven't been able to introduce it to you yet.
Our schedule!
De-den!
You might notice there's a little bit of an update at the bottom.
Nothing to be concerned about yet.
Wednesday, we have another FUWAMOCO Morning together!
And in the evening, some Donkey Kong Country too!
Let's see how this nest is doing.
I'm very confident in it.
I'm sure it's good.
Thursday morning, early morning at 4am PT, we're gonna be playing Chain together.
Yeah, we wanted to play, but there was no other time.
Yeah, we really wanted to play.
Ruffians, we wanna be able to spend as much time together as possible, but we do know that maybe some Ruffians will be deep asleep then.
Yeah.
So...
But we hope you know we can spend a little bit more time together and I know if you're gonna sleep, sleep then!
Then maybe you can check it out later when you're awake.
Yeah.
I know maybe needing a couple BAU BAUs here.
What happened to Portal?!
Don't worry!
It will be back.
Very soon.
Probably August.
I hope sooner.
Hopefully sooner.
Okay.
Thank you, Ruffians.
It might be a little bit of a wait, but it will be back.
It will be back.
I want to play Portal 2 together.
There's a lot of stuff coming, okay?
A lot of stuff.
It sounds silly, Ruffians, but there's a lot of things, exciting things that we want to do together that we have to do at a certain time.
Portal 2 is so crazy, okay?
BAU BAU.
And then we have an advent collab together!
We're gonna be chatting all about Japan and experiences so far.
Being silly.
And it's on Nerissa's channel.
Nerissa's channel!
And I didn't mention anything, but there might be an announcement too!
Maybe?
Yeah!
So?
Please join us, it'll be very comfy.
And now that we're awake, it's the summer of Advent after all!
And the Friday morning is FUWAMOCO Morning!
And a little bit different than usual, we have a Rock n' Rawr Party on the Friday!
Rock n' Rawr Party!
It's BAU!
We can't wait!
Ruffians, it's been such a long time!
Way too long!
So we're gonna sing a bunch of songs.
Some new ones, some favorites.
But Rock n' Rawr Parties will generally be at the regular time.
At the regular time.
A bit different this week.
Yeah, cause you can see on a Saturday, we're gonna be in Sydney for Slice!
We're gonna be doing some...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And let's BAU BAU all together!
And then Sunday, we made a little mistake.
We were like, oh!
It's gonna be Minecraft!
But then we remembered that we had a very very special thing planned.
We're gonna be playing Party Animals!
Advent vs Justin!
So, Minecraft will have to look forward to when it comes up next.
But, we're ready to be party animals and show justice, you know.
Exactly.
BAU BAU!
And that's our schedule for next- this week!
This week!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
And for the Ruffians joining us to the archive today, here's your FUWAMOCO word for the comments!
It's BAU BAU!
We're back!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm so happy, Ruffians!
We missed you so much!
We missed you a lot.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Night Owl!
BAU BAU!
That one!
Vulcan!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
Torch!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!